[Music]
eric is up next in boston massachusetts
erica how can we help
hi um so i have a question regarding
both my spouse and i being spenders
um
we have
three beautiful kids um ages six two and
four months
and i've been
using the every dollar budget about two
three months now and it just seems like
we keep going over [ __ ] i'm spending
on stupid things and you know i'm just
sick of being stupid about it i'm sick
of not being content
with what god has given me and um
i'm sick of acting pretty much like a
child with our money
and um i just want us to be adults about
it yeah um i want the adults with our
money
and you know like my mom's been trying
to help me to like stay on track but you
know i don't want to put that burden on
her
um so i've been calling her when i'm
feeling vulnerable about the spending
and she's been trying to help me through
it um
however i just want to know like for
some things that i can do like on a
daily basis on a weekly basis that can
help change the behavior
um because that seems to be the problem
like i'm really good with setting the
budget yeah where to go with like stuff
in my envelopes
um
how does it how does it what can i do
to help the behavior
so two things that come to mind my first
question is is your budget realistic are
you
setting a budget that is realistic with
your lifestyle erica like are you you
know i know this is a extreme example
but you're not putting like fifty
dollars for food
it's a reason it's a reasonable budget
it is and i guess like a little leeway
so i give he gets 80 a month to spend
and i get 80 a month
okay okay so my next question would be
what is causing you to spend what are
the things that are coming up that
you're spending and then you're
regretting
and you're thinking man i just want to
be content you know i heard you say that
so so what are the things are do you
guys have good community around you are
you lonely are you you know what what
what is the emotion i think he's just
like hobbies so like he canceled his gym
membership so we got a really basic like
dumbbells and like a bench so that we
can set it up in the basement and you
can do it in the basement yeah um and
then i i like to garden and like i just
i've always wanted um to get just like
you know just little pots so i can plant
my seeds and that's literally
what we overspent on this month and it's
just like those little hobbies so that
we can enjoy our home without having to
spend going out yeah yeah and it's just
so stupid when i like think i get that
like fire's remorse about it because i
have three little babies depending on me
and i can't live this way anymore
and i just wanted to stop yeah
absolutely well i hear it in your voice
erica and and and i don't want
it it feels like um
you have so much shame and so much guilt
of it which part of it i i understand
because you feel like you're making the
same mistake month after month so you're
frustrated with yourself so i hear that
but i also want to relieve you to say
like everyone screws up erica like at
nobody even even sitting behind this
desk every ramsey show like nobody's
perfect when it comes to money so
they're going to be mistakes um so are
you guys tell me more about your
situation how much how much debt do you
guys have how much y'all make a year
so we have about like 50 000 like that
okay um
most of it like um 30 of it is my my
school loans which
he even took on an extra job um so that
we can pay that off more and put it in
600 a month plus what he's getting paid
on his side job okay what's going on
what's the other 20 what's the other 20
the other 20 is the car loan okay how
much do you guys make a year
um we make
um
take home in 64 000. okay
um okay so
what i want you guys to do and you've
done it
is the budget okay so that budget is
going to help in the nuts and bolts of
this idea but when things come up that
you feel like
i want to spend but i can't call your
mom you're not being a burden she is
someone in your life that's going to be
able to help walk with you through that
and then i want you guys have a detailed
plan of how you're going to be paying
off the car first the 20 000 and then
the student loans i want the debt
snowball dialed in and i want an end
date to say how much when this can be
when we can be out of debt i need a
motivation for you
um but with your it's your kids it's
getting out of debts and the motivation
but erica give yourself some grace girl
breathe give yourself some grace and
it's a it's a daily grind so you wake up
and you make your decisions and you do
there's a level of grown-up-ness there
that you need to have